making my favorite I ain't going to lie
my guys be hitting
though what's up it's your boy CJ out
here with Bleacher Report usually I see
me on Saturdays here I'm back looking at
tailgates having a good time and
supporting my
Buckey I miss being in Columbus
everybody's so nice and welcoming so got
a lot of love out here for people so I
appreciate it it's a lemonade so you
know first buy us some
fire oh yeah my guys be hting though for
real what time is it 9:00 in the morning
we got it's 10:14 I Ain no barbecue no
10:14 but looks good though it's cool
man H it's it's not something I want to
do I want to go play but this is for
noon games when it's like you need a
good breakfast okay thank you cuz I went
to the another spot and they had
barbecue yeah like not nobody's even
Barbe yeah you know what I'm saying you
can have just bacon bacon my favorite I
ain't going to lie
f
I'm trying I need to talk to you I need
to I'm trying to have a farm in these
next couple
years he caught that
easy we going to mess up the recruitment
n my unofficial visit my first time at
Ohio State October 5th my birthday
weekend I flew from the game and I flew
with my ankle tape on so it's kind of a
crazy story like I got to the team hotel
and I asked for scissors uh because I
had to cut my ankle tape off from the
game so n that's good memories man that
was my first time ever in Columbus Q was
the The Alley guy for sure they they q a
lot of
money talk me to it little bro so all
right I didn't really set it up I know
someone that did so you got some some
brisky that's brisky right there okay
wings okay when y'all prepare all this
food the night before or this morning
this morning this morning wow so you had
to get up early
yeah wow my preference of a tailgate
I don't know I feel like I like this
this type of stuff but I couldn't eat
none of this in the morning so I would
prefer like more breakfast but like a
night game this one would be
perfect how's everything going it's good
to see you what's up bu good to see you
bro how you been good I miss y'all man
is your brother here oh no he he didn't
make it he's going to be mad yeah
there's DKI right here
everybody thank you so much love you bro
love you gang How You Bing man been out
this tunnel a th thousand times first
one is like a spectator so I miss
playing but you know support my guys
what's wrong with
[Music]
you man I'm so proud I missed
you that man the myth The Legend
juu baby love you bro good X what's good
brother crazy
bro
see man how you do man how are you man
up see mank you man thank you thank you
for coming so man I'm going with the
Buckey um I think we're come out with
this thing a little early man I
definitely think our defense is going to
maybe even go with a shut out uh so I'm
definitely going with the Buckey
[Applause]
man bu man yeah go ahead boo
y feels good though man be back home see
all my brothers man it's a blessing